parents need to understand that while we
certainly hope that our schools our
teachers our principles guidance
counselors are all wonderful people who
only want the best for their students we
have to live in reality and recognize
that well some of them do have an agenda
and that may not be healthy for our
children Dr Miriam Gman Child and
Adolescent psychiatrist also one of the
stars of our film what is a woman she
now has a new book out excellent
important book called Lost in trans
Nation a child psychiatrist guide out of
Madness Dr Gman thanks for taking the
time thank you so much for having me and
thank you for all you do Matt in this
space I was just this morning enjoying
some of the you know some of your posts
on on X and some of the other things
you've done and I really appreciate it
you're one of the leaders well um I
appreciate that and I appreciate you as
well you know you have a a real uh
important insightful perspective on all
the gender Madness I'm curious about one
thing what um what did you think was
kind of or what do you think is missing
from the conversation around this issue
or what
point uh is not being emphasized enough
or well enough understood that prompted
you to for example to to write the book
well you know I want to start with some
good
news um because I'm always presenting
very disturbing information and I will
certainly answer your question but I
want to tell you Matt you may not be
aware that our favorite
pediatrician Dr Michelle forcier is
being sued and if there's any of your
audience who are not aware who she is
she is the infamous blue-haired
pediatrician who POS that question to
you do chickens commit suicide in your
documentary what is a woman Dr forcier
is being sued finally by one of her
patients who
detransitioned and apparently this young
woman was extremely mentally ill and had
all sorts of psychiatric issues and I
have to say the lawyers are jumping on
these cases and I'm so happy to see it
after all these years yeah that that's
the the the the chicken lady as we have
come to call her is you're you're
exactly right and do you do you think
that this is the beginning of kind of
the floodgates opening we've all been
sort of waiting for this that uh this
was always the next step in the fight
for team sanity was that we start
holding these doctors accountable so do
do you think that there's evidence that
this is like the beginning of uh this is
just the tip of the iceberg yes
absolutely and it's not only the
individual doctors that are being sued
the American Academy of Pediatrics
is also
named uh as a defendant so this is
fantastic because the American Academy
of Pediatrics that claims that they
represent 67,000 pediatricians has been
for many many years completely captured
by this ideology and the way that it
happened is that a small group of
activists from within that organization
simply took over this particular subject
and started um you know writing policy
statements and articles and guidance for
other doctors and for parents and none
of it is uh is
evidence-based they claim that it's
evidence-based it is not it is a belief
system that we are not that our
identities are completely separate seate
from our bodies that we can be born in
the wrong body and that that is not an
emotional problem that's a physical
problem and you need to modify the body
to fit the feelings these are irrational
ideas these would not fly in any other
field of
medicine so yes this is very big I think
the tide is definitely turning there's
been a lot of successful legislation
and now these lawsuits are beginning
like I said not only against the
pediatricians and the therapists and the
endocrinologists and the
surgeons but also against the medical
organizations so this is good very good
it's definitely very good well and I
know you're not a lawyer of course but
do do you uh and I always air on the
side of being somewhat cynical about
these things so My worry is that
obviously uh the the victims that are
following these lawsuits should win
easily and they should win many millions
of dollars but you worry about the
courts just being ideologically stacked
against them so do do you feel good
about the chances of like this
particular lawsuit of of having success
given that problem you know you you're
correct to bring up you know who's gonna
who's the judge who are the
attorneys uh you know if there's a jury
who's on the jury but then my experience
testifying in court has been very
positive
actually and when you get a judge who
is you know middle of the road open
wants to learn someone who wants to
learn and to hear both sides then
definitely you know there can be a
success at the end of it but you're
right it does it is going to depend
depend a lot on the judges but I'm I'm
still hopeful because it's certainly
better than nothing and you know we'll
get the media coverage and we'll get
more and more um young people who went
through affirming care will have the
courage and the motivation to stand up
and
talk I'm curious about your uh General
assessment of I guess we've already kind
of got into this but your general
assessment of of the battle as it stands
right now
um are you now we talked about the the
lawsuits the success with
legislation uh but culturally speaking
do you do do you do you feel like um
we're making a lot of progress there I
actually do I I feel like you know even
aside from legislation now we've got
what's going on with litigation which is
really important but it seems to me that
culturally is where we can really see
the victory even more because it it
seems as though people are willing to
speak out against this much more than
they were back when we first started
filming the the movie back in 2021 for
example so do do you even more than yeah
even I I I do agree with you the thing
is look this is a battle that the truth
is going to win the question is how many
you know what's what's the body count
going to be and the body count from
where I'm sitting is very high because
it's not just the kids who end up you
know medicalized and
forever um disfigured and some of them
are going to be sterile and in not
capable of having biological children
but you see the families the families
are also victims the parents and the
siblings and the extended family because
you know this battle that that is
created inside the home when a child
announces a um a a a new identity an
impossible identity it it can tear a
family apart it can end
marriages um sometimes the child is so
indoctrinated that they believe anyone
that is hesitant or has questions or
wants to be cautious is the enemy and
that their homes are toxic they run away
there are websites I talk about this in
my book there are websites run by
activists who are advising kids on how
to run away where to run to they provide
them with uh financial help they tell
them you know call this number or uh
text this number and we'll come pick you
up and take you to a friendly home a
home where they will affirm you so
there's a lot of
terrible things going on a lot of
families in which these kids become
estranged uh
terrible pain and mourning that parents
go through so yes there is
progress but at the same time there's a
lot of victims and there's a body count
absolutely you mentioned uh you talked
about families and and kids that get
that that fall into this they no fault
of the parents so I want to ask you
about that on a kind of on a more
personal and practical level because I
hear from parents all the time who
either have kids who Fallen victim to
this or they're worried that their kids
will potentially fall victim to it you
of course have talked to many more
parents than me on this issue so I want
to take both of those cases individually
so first of all um would you say are
some basic steps a parent can take
proactively especially if their kids are
in public school or something and they
want to make sure they want to inoculate
their kids as best they can against yes
falling into this that's my my book is
an inoculation I want parents to start
really early I mean as soon as your kid
is talking and kind of understands boy
girl you know that identity um it's not
too early to say things like you know
you've been a boy since the very first
moment that you existed when you first
started growing in your mother's tummy
or however you want to say it inside
your mommy your your mother you are a
boy that it doesn't depend on some
random Midwife or Doctor Who's in the
delivery
room I want kids when they first hear
that phrase sex assigned at Birth I want
kids even little kids to to stop and say
no no that's not right sex is not
assigned at Birth it might be recognized
at Birth of although now we recognize it
way earlier it's established and it's
established permanently at conception so
you can begin early on with kids and you
can say to them things like you know you
were always a boy or a girl and that's
great and there isn't only one way to be
a boy or a girl there are many infinite
ways of being boys girls men and women
and anyone that might come along and say
oh you're a girl and you know you're not
into fashion makeup you know you're into
playing soccer and you know you're I
mean all these regressive stereotypes
right that's a bunch of
baloney these stereotypes are a bunch of
baloney and we have to tell our kids
that you can be a girl or a boy in many
different ways there's no just one way I
also tell parents it's important that
they themselves accept that their
daughter may not be stereotypically
feminine and their son may not be
stereotypically masculine it may not be
the kid that you
expected accept it try very hard to
accept that your kid and not only I mean
you have six kids you know all about
raising kids they don't always end up
the way that we were expecting
but certainly when it comes to
masculinity and femininity you want to
accept who they are and what their
interests are and not necessarily you
know push them in the direction that you
think well boys you know have to be X Y
and Z so you can do all of that you also
of course want to inoculate your child
against so many of the ideas that are
out there not just the ideas about G
I mean that may that's the topic of my
book but there's so many ideas that
activists are just waiting outside your
door or inside the computer inside the
chat rooms and parents must get in
control of their of their kids internet
use one of the appendices in my book I
have seven appendices one of them is
written by an IT expert and it instructs
parents on all the different ways you
need to get in control of your of your
kids's internet use if you're not in
control of it and your kid is just
wandering around on the internet trust
me there are plenty of groomers out
there that are just eagerly waiting to
influence your child and I've had one
family after the next come to me and
their child has been groomed into these
beliefs of being the opposite sex on the
internet so that's one of the appendices
um another thing a family can do early
on is put the school on notice and I
have a entire chapter about schools
parents need to understand that while we
certainly hope that our schools our
teachers our principls guidance
counselors are all wonderful people who
only want the best for their students we
have to live in reality and recognize
that well some of them do have an agenda
genda and some of them do want to
influence our kids and influence them in
ways that we wouldn't necessarily agree
with so you want to put the school on
notice and the way that you do that is
you download a form I actually have it
on my website my website is Miriam
Grossman md.com when you land on the
website you see a form putting schools
on notice you download it you print it
out it's free uh you sign it and you
give it to the principal of your school
your child may be in kindergarten it's
never too early that form is saying to
the school our family does not go along
does not agree with gender
ideology we do not give permission for
our child to be exposed to any of those
ideas whether it's in the classroom
whether it's in a special assembly or
meeting or a field trip to plan
Parenthood or um a guest who's going to
come and speak to the class an after
school club uh like a GSA Club one of
those we are prohibiting that we do not
give our permission and we hold you
responsible for any damage that may
result we definitely do not give our
permission this form says for our child
to be what's called socially
transitioned which means um to use a
different name for the child to allow
the child to use the opposite sex
bathrooms Etc this is socially
transitioning is not a benign
process it has
consequences and as far as we know we
don't have much research but as far as
we know it solidifies the
identity so whereas many of these kids
after a while they grow out of the
unhappiness the dysphoria that they have
with their physical sex if you if you
and it makes sense Matt right it it's
just common sense if you agree with the
child that their name is wrong and that
their pronouns are wrong and that they
need to live their lives as the opposite
sex
and use the opposite sex bathrooms Etc
and everyone in their lives all the
adults all the authorities are
agreeing then of course it's going to
solidify the child's belief and so I
caution very strongly against any kind
of social transition profiling
surveillance and data harvesting are a
few things not to like about tech Giants
but what can you actually do about it
when you rely on so many of products
well the good news is it doesn't take
much for you to take a stand for less
than $7 per month you can join me and
fight back against big Tech by using
expressvpn big tech companies make all
their money by tracking your searches
video history and everything you click
on and then selling your personal data
expressvpn helps you anonymize much of
your online presence by hiding your IP
address a unique identifier that every
device has that allows big Tech to match
your activity back to you that's why I
use expressvpn on all of my devices to
make it much more difficult for them to
exploit my data best part is how easy it
is to use the expressvpn app I just tap
one button on my phone or computer and I
turn it on and it's that simple your
data is your business visit
expressvpn.com Walsh YT use my Link at
expressvpn.com Walsh YT to get three
extra months free that's exp R vpn.com
walshy um I want we only have a couple
minutes left but I I I there's something
obviously related to this that I've uh
been wanting to ask you and I don't even
know if this is exactly true or not but
the way you know and it's but it's an
interesting pattern that I that I think
I've noticed which is um at the kind of
different age ranges which sex between
male and female is more susceptible to
this so we all kind of understand that
among adolescent kids girls are falling
into this much more often than boys are
it seems to
me that uh that younger than that though
young kids 5 six seven most of the time
when you hear about a young kid that
that age who's being as you say socially
transitioned usually it's a boy and then
you go into adulthood and you look at
the people who as adults start suddenly
identifying as trans it seems like
almost always with rare exception it's a
man so um I don't know have you noticed
that what do you what do you make of
that what do you make of like does the
age range and the sex of the person uh
make them more or less susceptible it's
a very important distinction and I go
through all of this in my book we've
always known about the little kids the
Jazz Jennings the bo the little boys who
from an early age insist that they
either are or have to become a girl and
we've always known about the middle-aged
men like Admiral Dr LaVine who in their
40s or or later decide that you know
these are these are men who are
heterosexual ual they have enjoyed
crossdressing um and going into women's
spaces they are sexually aroused by that
and we've always known about them they
um also sometimes will decide to go
through sex so-called sex reassignment
but now there's an entirely new
population um of kids who who are
suddenly out of the blue without a
history from childhood of wanting being
uncomfortable with their sex and these
are a majority although there's still a
lot of boys I mean my practice has
essentially been 50% boys and girls but
yes Matt you're bringing up something
very very important what we're looking
at now and everyone you see it's being
denied by the proponents of this but
those of us who are on the side of hard
science and hard evidence those of us
that are seeing these kids in our office
know that it is a social contagion and
it is fueled by the Internet by social
media by friend friend groups what is a
social contagion it's when ideas and
behaviors and beliefs are spread within
a friend group and it can be something
benign like a haircut or you know a way
of dressing or it can be something that
can be dangerous and look I've had kids
tell me I had a young woman in my office
who told me that she never had any
dysphoria any unhappiness about her
hips until one of her friends who's
transgender identified started
complaining about her hips I hate my
hips they're so wide they're so feminine
why can't I have narrow hips like a boy
boy all of a sudden my patient starts
having dysphoria about her
hips it is a social and this is also why
Matt a lot of kids who go into a
psychiatric uh inpatient unit they enter
that unit not being
trans they leave the unit a few weeks
later identifying as the opposite set or
non-binary or some other such nonsense
term because while in the hospital in
that psychiatric unit so many of the
kids probably more than 50 60% of kids
now who are in inpatient psychiatric
units for
adolesence do have some sort of gender
issue and so this is a big I write a
chapter in the book about the Dilemma
that a parent is in when they must Place
their child in one of these units
because they are suicidal or they have
some other acute emotional problem but
they don't want to do it because not
only are most of the kids suffering from
gender dysphoria on on that unit and it
and it will
spread but the staff on the unit more
often than not they are proponents they
are often activists they have been told
by their professional organizations and
by their Hospital
Administration that the first thing you
do when you meet a kid is you ask their
name and
pronouns and you give them your name and
pronouns I had a psychiatric nurse write
to me and she said Dr Gman I work with
these kids on an inpatient psychiatric
unit and I just can't I can't believe
what we're doing we start off asking
them their pronouns they're just
arriving they made a suicide attempt
they're being bandaged their wrists are
being bandaged and we're supposed to
begin with what are your pronouns what
name should I be calling you and she
ended up she quit she just quit we have
a big big problem yeah that's uh I I
guess I'm not surprised to hear that but
on another level it is shocking that
they would uh start with that level of
indoctrination when a kid is is that you
could not possibly be more vulnerable um
obviously there's a lot more to talk
about I wish we had uh more time to talk
about it but the good news is that uh
your book lost and transnation child
psychiatrist guide out of Madness um can
be purchased right now by anyone in um
where all these ideas are fleshed out uh
in even greater detail um I want to
mention also that I did the audio
version I I actually narrated the entire
book took 40 hours it was quite an
experience so um people are loving that
so for people who don't want to sit down
and read and they're commuting or
they're busy in the house or they're
jogging whatever you can listen to it on
audio every family needs the information
in my book please I'm begging you and I
and the fact that you narrated your own
audiobook I actually as a as an
audiobook snob myself uh I always prefer
for the author to read their own work so
I'm glad that you did that um and uh
that's also a great way to to uh access
this information as well Dr Gman uh
thanks so much for talking to us again
we really appreciate it you're welcome
Matt thanks for having
[Music]
[Applause]
me